encuentra la pendiente de la línea que
pasa por los puntos 42 y menos 316 como
un pequeño recordatorio la pendiente
está definida como el alza entre el
avance o dicho de otro modo el alza es
simplemente el cambio en y el avance es
simplemente el cambio en x este
triangulito es una de la mayúscula y
significa cambio en
así que esto es cambio entre cambio en x
esta fórmula a veces aparece también
como m que significa pendiente así que
esta es la pendiente que es igual a y
vamos a escribir lo mismo el cambio es
de 2 menos de 1 / x 2 x 1 que es el
cambio en x esto puede ser un poco
confuso pero sólo hay que recordar que
significa tomar la coordenada de su
segundo punto y reinstale la coordenada
del primer punto y eso te da el cambio y
luego tomar la coordenada y x el segundo
punto y reinstale la coordenada x del
primer punto y eso te da el cambio en x
en realidad todas estas fórmulas dicen
lo mismo pero bueno vamos a calcular la
pendiente de la recta que pasa por esos
dos puntos así que empezamos o de hecho
podríamos empezar en 4,2 y terminar en
menos 316 o empezar en menos 316 y
terminar en 42
vamos a hacerlo de los dos modos primero
vamos a considerar el caso en el que
empezamos en 4.2
y vamos a tomar el punto donde terminó
el punto terminal como menos 316
entonces cuál es nuestro cambio en xy
cuál es nuestro cambio a ver nuestro
cambio en x para empezar empiece en 4 y
baje a menos 3 así que cuanto cambie en
la coordenada x pues tuve que retroceder
7 espacios tengo que irme en reversa 7
lugares así que el cambio en x es de
menos 7 pues retrocede lo mejor es que
vamos lo así
el cambio en x es igual a menos 3 menos
4 y esto es menos 7 y esto significa que
empecé en 4 y retrocede hasta menos tres
así que el cambio en x es de menos 7 en
realidad esto está usando la fórmula que
tenemos por acá nuestro cambio en x es
x2 que es menos 3 - x 1 que es 4
pero bueno vamos a hacer nuestro cambio
y nuestro cambio y empiezo en 2 y
terminó en 16 así que en realidad subí
14 unidades o dicho otro modo siempre es
en 2 y subía hasta 16 entonces subí 16 -
214 unidades y entonces ahora bien cuál
es la pendiente pues la pendiente es el
cambio y entre el cambio en x pero esto
simplemente es 14 que es el cambio y
entre el cambio en x que es menos 7
así que bueno simplificando esta
fracción obtenemos menos 2 ese es el
valor de nuestra pendiente menos 2 ahora
vamos a ver que en realidad pude haber
comenzado con el punto menos 316 y
terminar en el 42 y lo que hubiera
pasado es que la segunda si bien han
intercambiado pero hubiéramos obtenido
el mismo valor para la pendiente muy
bien así que pensemos ahora que
empezamos en el menor 3 16
y pensemos que terminamos en el 42
en esta situación cuál es nuestro cambio
en x pues empecé al menos 3 y termina en
4 así que avance me fui a la derecha por
siete unidades así que sería 4 menos
menos 3 que sería 7 y ahora cuál es
nuestro cambio
pues ahora empecé en 16 empecé en 16 y
terminé en dos así que entendí adba g-14
unidades
así que el cambio sería negativo o dicho
de otro modo de 2 menos de 1 sería 2
menos 16 que es menos 14 y la pendiente
sería menos 14 que es el alza entre el
avance que es de 7
así que noten como sólo se
intercambiaron los signos y de nuevo la
pendiente vale menos 2
bien pues ahora vamos a hacer una
gráfica para ver qué significa que o
métrica mente que tengamos este valor de
pendiente negativo así que aquí tengo mi
eje x y acá tengo mi eje y primero vamos
a colocar en la gráfica los puntos menos
3 16 y 42 y después vamos a unirlos con
la línea recta
tengo 1234 4,12 así que aquí tengo el
punto 42 y luego tengo menos 3 16 así
que tengo 3 unidades a la izquierda y
luego subo 16 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 6
menos 316 aquí está
los 3,16 y la línea que pasa entre estos
dos puntos favoritos para dibujar
y va por ahí
así que más o menos es así la línea y
obviamente continúa en ambas direcciones
noten como la pendiente es negativa
mientras la x crece la ye se hace más
pequeña así que va de la izquierda
superior a la derecha inferior y esto es
lo que significa una pendiente negativa
ahora para visualizar cuanto como
cambiaron las coordenadas siempre se en
4 y termina el menos 3 si empieza en 4,2
y terminan menos 316 entonces empieza
aquí y termina ya me cambio en x
significa retroceder 7 unidades
mi avance no es un avance sino un
retroceso de siete unidades por eso al
menos siete y luego subo en la dirección
y durante catorce unidades y esto sí es
positivo porque estoy subiendo así que y
obtuve no está pendiente menos dos ahora
si hubiera empezado acá y terminado ya
si empiezo en menos 316 y terminó en 42
entonces primero si avanza en dirección
x durante 7 unidades y luego bajó en la
dirección y bajó 14 unidades pero como
estoy bajando son menos 14
pero de nuevo obtengo la pendiente menos